it is the final day of the pre-season
and before you know here's the reality
we've got 16 games tonight nobody cares
nobody about the 16 games tonight but
we've we've got four
guys who are still holding out i mean
think about this there were five
holdouts when training camp opened
michael thomas signed his contract
fairly quickly there are still four left
ezekiel elliott melvin gordon trent
williams and jadavian clowney so big
picture here's the over under here's the
prop bet to start the show okay over
under 1.5 will show up for week one you
taking the over you're taking the under
uh i'm going the under right now yeah
i'm going the under all the way
uh
i just i don't know if any of them are
going to show up right now the only guy
i even look at that remotely maybe has a
chance is if jodevion clowney something
happens there
maybe melvin gordon comes to his senses
which i wish he would because i don't
think he's got leverage there but trent
williams zeke elliott that's not
happening i don't see it yeah look i i'm
going to take the over you are going to
take over okay i think melvin gordon
because melvin gordon he's in his fifth
year option he's subject to fines in the
amount of a game check for every
preseason game he misses so after
tonight's going to be about 1.3 1.4
million just in fines from missing
preseason games and then it changes
the prospect of being fined
changes dramatically when you're looking
at lost money that's never coming back
right and i think what the chargers will
likely do at some point between now and
next thursday or friday i don't know
this but i think what they'll do is
they'll say hey melvin look you're gonna
start losing 329 000 a week that's never
coming back if you come back now we'll
waive all your fines yeah we we've got
the 30 000 a day in training camp fines
we've got 1.4 million in you've missed
the pre-season fines and that all goes
away and you're going to get your 329
000 a week are you ready to come back
he's got no other option he's got no
other alternative yes i think he'll be
back and i also think the next guy we're
going to talk about will be back because
yeah look it's it's cost him nothing so
far chris
but as of next week it's a million
dollars per game at least for him to not
be present for the texans and that
analysis i think changes everything as
well so i say over you say under we'll
find out in 10 days whether that
actually is the case
you don't think trenton williams or zeke
elliott are going to be that there that
you you think that's not happening i
don't either i don't see the zeke thing
coming into uh an end here at any time
soon
yeah i think the two are gonna be gordon
and clowney and let's talk more about
clowney because it seems like every hour
there's another development about the
hold out texans linebacker defensive and
again he's not being fined it's not
costing him anything
until he starts missing regular season
games and there have been reports that
he's willing to miss regular season
games and reports that the texans have
spoken to five different teams about
trading him and look chris let me just
start with this from clowney's
perspective a lot of people in the media
are saying he's got all the leverage he
holds all the cards well yeah until he
starts missing million dollar game
checks right it's it's expensive
leverage for jadavian clowney for now it
doesn't cost him anything to say to the
texans hey you can't trade me until i
sign my franchise tender that's fine
it's free for him to not sign the
franchise tender if he chooses to miss
regular season games because he's
concerned he's going to sign the tender
and then get traded to miami where he
doesn't want to play
that's going to be very expensive yes
when the regular season rolls around
that's the one thing we need to keep in
mind before we praise you davey and
clowny for being in this great position
it's going to cost a lot every week to
stay in that position starting next week
it is it's going to cost a lot and i
know when you're out there looking from
the outside in and we just go whoa how
could you do that how could you turn
down a million dollars a week holy cow
and i understand that too but i still
think in the bigger picture of things
i'm sure devion clowney and the people
around him are going yeah but if you go
out there and play
and do something to your knee or do
something else like that then wow you're
going to lose more than a million
dollars a week when it's all said and
done on your next contract or anything
that you want to get guaranteed
money-wise and that he's really going to
be in a hole there so he's yes he's
risking some some money loss now to
hopefully make more money in the end and
more guaranteed money in the end to set
up his future life and his family and
everything like that so it's a very
delicate balance it's like we talked
about with le'veon bell last year uh and
you just really as a player got to kind
of kind of figure that out but i'm
really intrigued to see what happens
here too mike just because and chris
yeah go ahead what's the end game here's
the thing the end game for bell last
year even if you didn't realize it at
the time yeah the end game was because
he was tagged the second time sit out
the whole season
and then you become a free agent as a
practical matter the next year because
the steelers aren't going to franchise
tag you again they don't transition tag
him he walks away and signs with the
jets but for clowney
he doesn't become a free agent by
sitting out all of 2019 no so
that money is never coming back and it's
not it's not as a practical matter
pushing him toward
that long-term deal because he can't be
signed to a long-term deal if he's
traded to another team they cannot sign
into a long-term deal and and uh i i
think the bigger picture here is from
the texans perspective remember what
they went through in june they fired
brian gaine
they tried to hire nick casario to be
the new gm they ultimately didn't hire a
gm right and then july 15 comes and goes
i think if they hadn't gone through all
that turmoil and upset they may have had
a better plan that would have been
implemented
before july 15. that's all i've thought
about really the last few days is what
would it have been like if nick casario
was there or if there was truly an
acting gm would there have been a better
plan put forth i mean billy o'brien i
know he's a smart football guy and a
real good football coach and all that
too but he it just you can't balance
everything sometimes when you're
coaching the team you can't sit there
and come up with plans of as far as how
you're going to handle certain guys in
the trade market and do everything there
you need a little help bill belichick
has nick casario there to help him along
with that he trusts them to get some of
that nitty-gritty stuff out of the way
and then cassario can come with them and
go hey here's the plan i think that
might work best what do you think bill
and they'll bounce things back off each
other yeah there's i don't know what's
going on or the pecking order in houston
but clowney uh i i hear you mike i mean
too the other thing is i just his his
long-term contract
prospects
they're shaky anyways you said it
yesterday this is a guy who had micro
fracture surgery you know that scares
the hell out of people in the nfl i
would say that's one two top three
scariest injuries in the sport right now
right mike i mean micro fracture surgery
patella tendon and maybe something with
your neck those three things right there
alone get you in a little black book in
about every 30 and all 32 teams that go
oh we need to really do our due
diligence and we end up signing this guy
and and you know i don't know if he's
going to get a long-term contract uh you
know or the money he really wants when
all said and done end game even next
year um you know when he is a free agent
or wherever and he can negotiate a
contract
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports